towns plane it came back this year but
you know what when they say when they
say to like movie stars oh you're making
a comeback like what's your name what's
that movie Oh like Sunset Boulevard
she's like I I never went away and Chuck
II never really went away I mean we've
made seven Chucky movies I made forward
Don Mancini wrote every Chucky movie
from the beginning of time they just
decided to do her a reboot of the Chucky
movie so it sort of is it's really
strange because the new Chucky is you
know it was a really great film but it's
sort of like that movie us like there's
something that looks like Chucky and
sounds buddy is kind of not Chucky so
it's like where you go down the hall of
mirrors and you meet yourself coming
like in a horror film and you're like ah
that looks like me but it's not me so
it's been a very interesting year but
yes you could all you could argue that
the energy that kind of stepped on the
original child's play to make this room
kind of bid it in its butt a little bit
when they look at the box-office
so you want to see Don Mancini come back
the original Chucky crew come back and
you as well it got great reviews I think
was actually good for the whole Chucky
franchise because it renewed interest
the fans loved both movies but you know
it is true then people were sort of like
it's kind of like New Coke and Coke
Classic then people are like well the
new cokes good but we want to see the
Coke Classic again so we're doing a
Chucky television series Don's writing
it and it's gonna be really interesting
because he gets to explore a lot of the
aspects of Chucky they weren't covered
in some of the recent movies and he can
go backwards and forwards in time I'm
not saying that's what he's going to do
I'm helping you write it by saying hey
Chuck
don't make sure there's a part in it for
me yes yes what's it what's it what is
it about the Chucky franchise that has
kept you for so long intrigued
interested in wanting to come back to it
dun dun ro da da and wrote all the
Chucky I'm saying Don say something oh I
thought you were just like the reason
she came back is because she likes me so
much I'm so nice in such a good director
and writer
yeah well we do enjoy working together
we've known each other for 20-some years
now see your museum is that Don loves a
horse Chandra and when he writes from a
fan's perspective when he's writing he
never says I'm gonna do a revamp of what
before like sometimes people are like oh
let's have Chuck yet this environment or
let's how Chucky kill like another
teenage girl he's always like what would
I want to see and there's an ongoing
story so it's like a soap opera like
about 20 years ago Chuckie got married
and then he had a kid and so there's
always something new and the Chucky
franchise so people never get bored
because it's never what came before and
he always has an eye to the fans like
the last movie that he did he brought
back the one who played the little boy
in child's play now he's like this
40-year old bearded vigilante and
understandably bitter about what he went
through when he was a child and he
brought back Christina Lee so it was
also in the early child's place movie so
he does it for the fans done you know
done loves the Chucky movies more than
possibly more than anybody else but he
has an insane fan base I mean all over
the world I never thought that that's
what I would be famous for but you know
it's my fault I did four of them so
everywhere I go I step off the plane in
countries I didn't even know existed and
they know one word and it's Chucky they
don't they scream Chucky then they run
over and hug me so it speaks to people
does it's a right there's a rabid fan
base amongst our horror pundits here at
Collider so we love child's play Thank
You Jennifer there's so much great to
beg you Don contains success on the TV
series